no support discipline discipline
discipline discipline discipline
discipline discipline discipline
discipline
hello believed nation today we're going
to talk about how you can develop
discipline and as always guys as you're
watching if you hear something that
really inspired you please leave it down
the comments below put quotes around it
as well so other people can be inspired
and when you write it down it's much
more likely to sink into yourself as
well enjoy so Tony one of the critics
actually that I once met said yeah
Tony's techniques they were great for
about a year and a half and then they
wore off what do you say to that so it's
real simple if you don't work out you
don't get a you don't get a muscle right
I always tell people this is there's a
daily practice like grinding if you
don't do that if you get up and you have
no discipline whatsoever you get no
value of anything your diets don't work
when you don't do the exercise doesn't
work when you don't do them but most
people have some experiences that they
want to shift and once you shift those
things your whole life changes but life
is constant growth my life isn't here
because I went to one seminar one time
and now my life is fit for life I I work
out I train my mind I train my body it
becomes a lifestyle it's not just like
you're depending upon somebody else I'm
gonna here to become somebody's guru I'm
not here to give them a gift I'm here
them to open up their own gifts and
that's really what my work has been I've
never met a person who is not successful
that didn't have a great amount of
self-discipline within their life
self-discipline and being able to
perform and being able to keep your life
on schedule and being able to keep
commitments and promises and meet
deadlines is essential to success none
of us none of us can afford to have a
life that is controlled by someone else
or a life that is basically controlled
by our emotions I learned many years ago
that there are two kinds of people
there's the type of person who says I'm
going to wait till I feel like it before
I do it and then there's a person who
says I've got to do it so that I feel
like it one will never get anything done
because they're sterile waiting to feel
the moment to move and the other person
says no I need to move and then I will
begin to feel the moment Sonia
self-discipline is essential in your
life and in my life if we're going to
get things done so I have a challenge
for every one of you this weekend the
challenge is simple as you go through
your weekend and sometimes it's kind of
a hopefully an easier time of your week
ask yourself am i practicing
self-discipline in my life am i doing
the things that I should do because I
need to do them or am I kind of waiting
to feel the moment do like our friends
Nike say just do it how different do you
think your career possibly your life
would have been had you not embraced the
physical fitness part early on oh man
you know it just gives me between my
physical fitness and my faith I have so
much discipline in my life and I have
such a positive outlook on life and you
know the opportunities that I have and
the things that I've been able to
accomplish in my life so it starts out
you know I'm up in the 4:30 in the
morning I'm in my kitchen having
breakfast 5 o'clock I'm in the gym 6:30
I've already had another shake and 7:30
I'm eating a couple turkey burgers
dropping the kids off at school and by 9
o'clock I'm having another meal and I've
already been to church and worked out
and you know I feel like there isn't
anything that I can't accomplish when I
was in high school I must have been
maybe 16 or 17 years old and I went rock
climbing in Eldorado Canyon where I near
where I grew up in Boulder I've been
climbing about 3 or 4 years and I want
to do a climb called t2 now the time t2
is a relatively difficult climb and I
went at it with a kind of an arrogant
lack of preparation and I hadn't
prepared for being able to do certain
kinds of finger cracks I've got I figure
I'll figure it out when I get there and
I also didn't pause this is I think
about boldness and discipline I didn't
pause to really double smack double
check all my systems
okay so I'm on the fourth pitch I'm
about 400 feet above the ground I'm
going across this slanting crack system
that I'd had trouble that I started at
home with my forearms started to engorge
with blood and lactic acid which means
at some point even if you're on a big
hold your hands are going to melt off
Kevin and I'm about to fall
I'm 400 feet above the ground but it
should be okay because there's
protection
I'm tied into the rope I may take a fall
but I'll get caught for some reason them
to this day I still don't know why my
brain triggered that I should look at my
knot and I looked down at my not my not
had come untied I had made the mistake
of jinking about the best not for
certain types of situations and I tied
him with what's a bowling now the
advantage of a bowling is it's easy to
untie if you write the disadvantage of a
Boldin is easy to untie it had come
untied as I kept moving across and it is
just hanging in my harness I'm seconds
away from falling only now I will die I
will die if I fall off my forearms are
melting and the knot had come untied and
so I called down to my partner I said by
knocking on time what's he going to do
he can't do anything you just watch me
fall to my death and I there was an old
fixed Pete hook in the rock that would
put there from the first descent an old
soft iron Pete on and I looked at it and
I probably had 15 20 seconds before my
hands with a rat if that maybe 10 I took
a runner and I clipped it into the Piton
I clipped the Pete on into my heart that
runner into my harness and just went
please hold
and I let go and it helped
I put in a backup I grabbed the not be
tied it went to the legend convulsion
okay it was very common that moment I
got to the ledge I went into convulsive
shaking I was sick to my stomach for
days because of the whatever happened
chemically what I learned from that is
two things the first is that when you're
in an unforgiving world gravity is
unforgiving it doesn't care it never
takes a day off ever and if you make one
mistake it can kill you if it's the
wrong kind of mistake and what I learned
is that sense of it yeah I want to do
adventurous things I don't want to climb
rocks I want to be in Yosemite I want to
do things that get my adrenaline coin.i
but I need the discipline to always do
all the right preparation to always
think about the right nuts to always be
cross-checking my system so that I can
do those bold things and stay alive in
an unforgiving environment and as you
and I spoke about earlier today I think
that's the rest I think we are all
heading into an unforgiving environment
where we're going to have to be both
bold and disciplined the second thing I
learned what if that Piton had not been
there we might not be here together it
was just by chance that that Piton was
right there and once you realize when
you rewind the tape of your own life is
that there are these crucial moments
where if the luck had gone the other way
you might have gotten killed and so what
you have to do is to always be X putting
those extra disciplines in place because
I was lucky to live and what I took from
that is I never want to have to be lucky
to live again I want to live because of
my discipline not because of my walk
going on perhaps a decade of running
simultaneously to two global companies
how do you get the stamina to to keep
going and to stay fit you know
personally and mentally and physically
well you know somebody said with a
little discipline you do little things
with a lot of discipline you do a lot of
things and we spoke to discipline
there is nothing which you cannot do it
requires a lot of discipline I mean
obviously because you're going to move
from one world to the other from one
culture to the other from two completely
different company
yeah jet LAG's organization people are
expecting you when you come down from a
plane after 14 hours flight to be fresh
and ready for them but they're not
expecting the CEO to come and say oh my
god is jet lag you cannot answer a
question they want you to be on the go
all the time so this requires a lot of
discipline you have to organize yourself
if you know you're going to do this job
and you accept the job you have to
organize yourself in order to do it it's
tough but there is a solution there is
there is a solution for it but it
requires a lot of choices personal
choices there are a lot of things you
cannot do you know there are lots of
things you can do but you're going to do
them within a certain order but
particularly with a lot with the love of
discipline in 2009 when the mixtape and
and there was a period where I think
around that time you were kind of like
you know is this something that's going
to work for me or not um what is it that
got you through how did you how did you
work through that yeah it's tough to say
exactly what I think it was hard work it
was it was discipline it was knowing
that if this doesn't work out then I
will have to get a nine-to-five and I
don't want to do I really don't want to
do that and it was it was working with
Ryan and putting everything into the
music and you know for I mean leading up
to that point I think that you have to
look at my track record I had always
wanted to get sober I could never get
sober
I was met I couldn't make music while I
was under the influence of drugs or
alcohol
finally got sober in 2008 got out of
rehab and was like I this is it I wasted
years of my life and if this is going to
work it has to work now there's no
alternative and I met somebody that had
the same dedication as me that put
everything into the music everything
into the craft and didn't go out didn't
really have
have many friends haha just kidding just
kidding huh well you only hang out with
each other huh
no it's somebody that it wasn't going to
you know be like you know I was up in to
that point I was making musical people
that were constantly putting their
priorities into getting cooler people
getting no not at all yes getting um
getting loaded or chasing women or
whatever and that's what I did for a
long time and it didn't it led me to
being broken and Rehab me moving back
into my parents house which is awesome
but um I I wanted a career in in Ryan
with somebody that had the same
discipline yeah and sacrificed
everything what my dad always told us
and we're going up that if you end a
dollar you don't save anything
if you end end it billion dollar you
will save anything
and so that discipline of investment
keeping something don't cause him
everything you get actually helped me
significantly those core moments that
you know fill the highlight reels and
you know we've an audience and all the
watch oh wow play that again I want to
see that those seconds of Bill burn
thousands and thousands and thousands of
hours that a lot of people wouldn't
think of worth you know adding to a
highlight reel
basic fundamentals being applied over
and over and over and over again filling
up a certain time doing certain things
cooking your meals going to you know do
your cardio walking through the
disciplines keeping the checklist and
staying on top of the goals or the
things that you know you string them
together start to create a day of
efficient action more likely you are to
string those days of fishing action
together the more likely it will be that
you can set up your own success
how would you personally describe your
style of leadership close to the human
being
I think discipline is very important
very important that discipline is
relative especially with which you when
you work together with young players and
yet never lose the target and I don't
know how to say that never lose the tie
it always means stay focused on it and
so that that's pretty clear because that
and always and yeah think it's still
possible so that's that's not right well
in English where I was here yeah for
sure belief it's a bit different to
believe belief system you can create you
can believe in something but it can lose
believed quite easily so to be stronger
in a bad moments things like this I
always wanted to win the World Cup
that was the reason I started and as the
time went by I started enjoying cricket
and I started realizing the challenges
of cricket and my coach was instrumental
and along with my brother to to my elder
brother [ __ ] to make me realize the the
importance of leading a disciplined life
a focused life and to to to to make me
push harder
they found reasons and and even towards
the end of my career I followed that
form
if I scored runs let the rest of the
world talk about it I think about the
next game and that right from my school
days became an unwritten formula
unwritten law at home that we don't talk
about last games we talk about next game
and however many runs I scored I wanted
to go out and score more than that so if
I didn't score I would have a restless
night if I scored runs I would still
have a restless night thinking that how
am I going to score more and that's how
it all happened I mean I I i normally
don't discuss numbers but this is
something that I must share with all of
you I towards the end of my school
cricket career I already started playing
first class cricket and the last season
I can proudly say that I averaged
thousand and twenty five because I only
got out once and the whole season
my brother and my coach was instrumental
in that because every time I scored runs
none of them said well played to me and
that's why in my farewell speech I said
I said to my coach at least now you can
take a chance by saying well done there
is there are no no more matches in my
career but something that that I lived
for was appreciation from my coach and
my brother which never happened I mean
and that was something which you know
sort of kept me giving giving my best
all the time thank you guys so much for
watching I love to know what did you
think of this video what was your
favorite clip and what are you going to
immediately apply to your life or to
your business somehow also how have you
developed discipline and do you have any
wisdom to share that others can learn
from leave it down the comments below
I'm going to join in the discussion
finally I'll give a quick shout out to
Judah Beck ooh I hope I pronounced that
okay thank you so much dude for picking
up a cup of my book your one word it
really really really really means a lot
to me and I hope you're enjoying it so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon